INTRODUCTION: The
following content
is provided by MIT
OpenCourseWare under a Creative
Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Specific
problem, and it's
a pure linear least
squares problem,
but it's got two terms.
So we're used to minimizing
A*u minus b square.
That gives us the least
squares solution u
hat to a linear system.
And usually the reason we have
to go to the least square thing
is that there's
no exact solution.
Probably A has more
equations than unknowns.
A is long and thin, and
there's no exact solution,
so we look for the best
solution, and we call it u hat.
OK.
But there are a lot
of problems in which
a second square appears.
There's also a B*u equal d
hiding in the background.
And so we really have like
two sets of equations.
And we multiply that second
square by some factor
alpha and that wise
choice of alpha
is usually a big
part of the problem.
And I want to speak about
some of the applications
of this area.
So from the point of view
of the normal equations,
the system that
you actually solve,
you could say no problem.
If we knew how to do
this, then we certainly
can do both of them together,
because instead of A transpose
A showing up, we'll now have
A transpose A plus alpha B
transpose A. That'll be the
positive definite coefficient
matrix on the left side.
And then on the
right side, instead
of just the usual
A transpose b, this
term is also going to give
us an alpha B transpose d.
All I'm saying is we don't need
any new mathematics to reach
this normal equation with the
-- sort of the two-term normal
equation.
And another way to think of
exactly the same thing is we're
looking at the least squares
problem, where the two matrices
A and B both are multiplying u.
And we have two bits
of data, b and d,
and all were doing
is the usual thing
but with a weight in here.
And the weight is the identity
matrix for the A part,
and it's alpha times the
identity matrix for the B part.
So this is our C right.
This is our C, just
to say that, really,
the notation that we created,
the formulation we have,
allows us to take this step, so
C appears here and A transpose
C*b, C appears over here
too, just as always.
OK.
But there are
important questions.
And of course, always, the
first important question
in applied math is what
problem are you solving?
Why have we produced
this class of problems?
And I have two answers.
Let me just mention
first, so we are sure what
the shape of these matrices is.
A, as always, has more
rows than columns.
Of course, u is n by 1.
It's just a column vector.
But A has too many
equations, too many rows,
for us to get an exact
solution; B, on the other hand,
has few rows.
It might even only have one row.
It's very common to add on
one constraint or one term
in regularizing the situation.
Anyway, p is relatively small.
So the total matrix A, B has
m plus p rows, and the same n
columns, and we're ready to go.
But the two parts are
different somehow.
They come for different reasons.
And now, I wrote down here
two places they come from.
And these are big
applications of applied math.
And one of them produces
small coefficients alpha.
And what's the purpose of the
B*u minus d term in that case,
with just a small alpha?
The problem is that
the A transpose
A part is nearly
singular or is singular.
So that the usual normal
equation, without the B,
would be in trouble, and this
of course happens pretty often.
So the idea of regularization
is get some control
of the solution by putting
in another term that
keeps some control over u, and
stops it from just taking off,
as what happened where the
original normal equations would
have a very large u hat.
So we're just, like, adding
a little steady part that
keeps it a bit under control.
And so the A transpose A is
nearly singular in ill-posed
problems, so we make them
-- it's like giving aspirin
to an ill-posed problem, right?
You don't fix it,
but it can operate.
OK.
And where do ill-posed
problems come from?
And I just wanted to say that I
think the fundamental ill-posed
problems in science
is: given positions --
suppose we know that
a mass, let's say,
is in certain positions
at certain times --
find the velocity.
So we often, in
applications have some way
to know position, and
want to know velocity.
And maybe you realize
that that problem is not
well posed, because velocity
takes the derivative.
And if you take the
derivative, that's
not a good operator to invert.
Taking the derivative
makes things very rough.
All sorts of cases, we're
looking for the velocity,
and we only have positions.
One that I think
about is from GPS.
So GPS uses space-based
satellites, as you all know,
to give you very
accurate positions.
And somehow, out
of those positions,
you get pretty accurate
but not, of course,
as accurate as the positions,
but you get decent velocities.
And how?
And there is an example where
you want to know the motion --
of course, to ask for the
acceleration would be asking
for yet another derivative.
You see why the derivative
is an ill-posed thing?
Let me just say
ahead of time, I'm
going to make today's lecture
about direction number two,
not the ill-posed problems.
So I'm just, like,
throwing in some comments
about the ill-posed
problem, and then
I'll have a weekend
to think about those,
and then next week,
I'll come back
to this ill posed problems.
And specifically, they often
come from inverse problems,
is a big source of
ill posed problems
that need regularization.
It's just a very large
class of equations.
I mean, I was just going to say
about the derivative example.
Why is that so unstable?
Well, from the point
of finite differences,
if we have positions, how
do you estimate velocities?
You take a difference
quotient, right?
You take the position at this
time, the position at a close
by time, and you
divide by delta t.
That's a reasonable start.
But dividing by delta
t, that small number,
is producing big numbers.
Any errors in the position
are multiplied by that 1
over delta t and blown up.
And similarly, in
frequency space,
where the functions that we
think about are the functions
like e to the i*k*t, the
derivatives brings down
the factor k.
So high oscillations,
that's the point.
Oscillatory functions
can be pretty small,
but their derivative
can be enormous.
So it's that oscillation
which is often associated
with noise in the measurements.
You know, noisy
measurements are jumpy,
and when we go to take their
derivative or their finite
difference, we get big answers.
Anyway, for me that's the
model ill-posed problem,
to find velocities.
And how to do it?
I mean a lot of thought
has gone into that.
Let me leave it there,
and come back to it.
But I say all this just to
emphasize its importance.
Not that we'll completely
solve it, actually,
for GPS or for any
other thing, it's
just all we can do is medicate.
OK.
Now this is the one that
we can really solve.
So this is a different
application entirely.
In this application, this
second term, B*u equal d,
is something important,
something that we want
to enforce.
It's a constraint,
you could say.
And one way to enforce it
which fits this pattern
is to take alpha
very large, right.
When we take alpha large, we're
putting a really heavy weight
on that B*u minus d square,
and when we minimize,
that weight will force B*u
to be pretty close to d.
But of course, B*u equal
d doesn't determine u.
Everybody's got
that picture clear?
From B*u equal d
has many solutions.
And so the real problem that
we're trying to solve is
enforce B*u equal d, but
among those solutions,
pick the one that
minimizes the first square,
A*u minus b squared.
So you see the difference?
You're trying to
enforce something
that the physics or the
geometry, or whatever
source says has to be true.
And you can do it.
And you're left with
lots of options.
And then the combined problem
attempts to pick the right u.
OK.
So that's the
application number two
that I want to
speak about today.
And actually, I want to
give several ways to do it.
It's a very important problem.
And one way will be to
actually solve B*u equal d.
Find those solutions.
And you may say,
well, that's what
we learned in linear
algebra, that's
the very foundation
of linear algebra,
is there a particular
solution, right?
Every solution is of this form
particular plus null space.
Maybe I'll just point to
the start of that approach.
So want to solve B*u equal d.
And I'll come back
to this method
after dealing with the
least squares approach.
But here's really
the direct approach.
That if I solve B*u equal
d, then there's a particular
solution that solves it.
And then you can always add on
the general solution which is,
sorry add on the null
space solution --
the solution of B*u equals 0.
And B*u equals 0 has
lots of solutions.
So we would have to find them.
OK.
I mean that's what 18.06
would naturally do,
but actually never,
I'm ashamed to say,
but I didn't do it in 18.06.
I never actually said how I
would scientifically compute,
in a stable way, the solutions.
OK.
So I think that
will be important.
But that's not the
only way to do it.
That's called the
null space method.
And sometimes it's the
right choice, sometimes not.
This would be called the
heavy weight method, right.
Put on a very heavy weight
and solve a standard problem.
OK.
So let me follow that one up.
And then they'll
be a third method.
And maybe there's going to be
space on the middle blackboard
for it.
And what would the
third method be?
That will be use a
Lagrange multiplier.
This thing is a constraint.
I'll enforce it by a
Lagrange multiplier.
OK.
That's coming next.
The way I'm enforcing it right
now is by a heavy weight.
OK.
One reason for the
popularity of this method
is you don't have to
do any new thinking.
You just create these
equations and solve them.
Where the other methods maybe
ask us to think separately
about the constraint.
Here we don't have
to things separately,
we just create this normal
equation, we solve it,
and we get an answer u hat.
Maybe I should call
it u hat alpha,
because it depends
on the weight alpha,
certainly, which we hope
is near the exact solution.
The exact solution being the one
that exactly solves B*u equal
d.
Because u hat alpha will not
exactly solve B*u equal d.
But we can find solutions
that do, and then among those,
we can minimize
A*u minus b square.
OK.
So just a word about
this heavy weight method.
OK.
Well, first an
interesting point.
A point that I think
is sort of interesting.
I want to let alpha go to
infinity and see what happens,
right.
Everybody figures that as
alpha goes to infinity,
I'm going to get
the right answer.
Because as alpha
goes to infinity,
it's going to more and more
enforce the constraint B*u
equal d.
And then, with that constraint
enforced, the other part of it
will find the best
u and that's great.
But let alpha go to
infinity in this equation,
and what happens?
So this is just like a side
comment just to say alpha,
you know, taking a limit you got
to think about doing it right.
Well, let's see, if I let
alpha go to infinity as it is,
that'll be infinite
that'll be infinite,
and I won't know
what's going on.
Let me divide by alpha before
I let alpha go to infinity.
So if I just divide
everything by alpha --
can I do that with
an eraser here?
I'll divide by alpha.
So there's a 1 over alpha here.
I divide this by alpha.
And this has a 1
over alpha there.
And now, if I let
alpha go to infinity,
I get something sensible.
This goes to 0, right,
alpha going to infinity,
getting bigger and bigger.
This goes to 0.
So what do I get in the limit?
I get that this equals
this in the limit.
So shall I put that up here?
Well, I'll put it here, because
I don't like it, frankly.
So I'll just squeeze
it in this little spot.
That if I let alpha go to
into infinity, so 1 over alpha
goes to 0.
I get B transpose B, u hat
infinity, shall I call it?
Equals B transpose d.
And I guess what I
want to say is, from
that I don't learn a whole lot.
because B transpose B
is a singular matrix,
B transpose B is a
matrix of only rank p,
it's very singular, right?
B had this crazy
shape, long and thin.
B transpose B will
be tall, B transpose
B will be a large matrix,
but its rank will only be p.
It's an n by n matrix
of rank p, and it's
singular and who knows
what's going on there.
That little side
issue was simply
to say that you
can't just let alpha
go to infinity in the
central equation there,
and expect to see
what's happening.
OK.
So somehow there's
more to it than that.
So let me put alpha back where
it belongs, and think again.
OK.
And I guess by thinking
again, I might as well
think in terms of this
way of writing it.
Because I recognize this, right?
This is exactly the framework
that we've developed.
So this is the least
squares problem.
I just want to write
down the saddle point
matrix that goes with this
least squares problem.
What is the saddle point matrix?
Do you remember?
The saddle point matrix S
is -- it has, up here --
so now I've got
an A and a B here.
So it's going to be
a little bit larger.
Then I have my usual zero block.
And I have my usual A
transpose B transpose block.
And what block goes there?
That's the C inverse, right.
It's our usual C inverse,
A, A transpose, 0
that we're totally
accustomed to.
But now A has grown
into A, B; 0 is still 0;
the transpose is
still the transpose;
and up here is C inverse,
and since C was this,
C inverse will be the identity,
and the identity over alpha.
OK.
So that's my S_alpha,
you could say.
And now I'm prepared to let --
so my equation is S_alpha --
written as a block equation,
what are the pieces of it?
u is the guy that I'm
looking for, the u hat alpha.
And there was a Lagrange
multiplier that came in.
You remember, that's how
we got to a block form
from a scalar form.
And I guess I usually call it
w, so I'll stay with w for here.
OK.
So that's what multiplies w, u.
And it's what
gives -- let's see.
I think it gives a B, and
it gives a d from this A*u
and B*u, and I think
here if gives a 0,
because we didn't have any.
OK.
What am I doing here?
I'm just writing
the problem in a way
where I can let alpha go
to 0, and see the limit.
So let alpha go to infinity,
this is heavy weight part.
So this will go to 0.
So this approaches the
S_infinity, w_infinity,
we could call it, u
hat infinity is now --
well you see what the limit
is, that's 0 in that block.
This is A, this is B, this is A
transpose, this is B transpose,
this is our usual zero
block, multiplying
our same w_infinity,
u hat infinity,
equaling our same b, d, and 0.
This is the limiting equation.
And it's great.
This is the equation that
determines the limit as alpha
goes to infinity, that
determines the best u.
This is the problem that
we really want to solve.
Maybe that's what I should say.
Do you see the constraint
B*u equal d in here from this
middle block row?
That says 0, 0, B u hat is d.
So we've introduced
the constraint.
The first part is w_infinity
with an A*u_infinity,
that's the usual error term,
the thing that we probably
can't make 0.
And then this is the
usual Lagrange multiplier
term from there.
So I've spoken pretty quickly
here, and let me just conclude.
This is the limit equation,
is the correct limit equation.
This is the limit
equation that we want
to solve one way or another.
And taking alpha large is one
way to get near the answer,
but we'll look at
other ways now.
So this is really the
correct equations to solve.
Going the saddle point
Lagrange multiplier route.
OK.
So let me summarize
what I've done so far.
My problem is when B*u equal
d is a constraint that I would
like to satisfy, and one way
to do it is to take alpha,
you know, pretty near the
largest number that the machine
will hold, say 10 to the 15.
Put a really heavy
weight on this.
But of course, when you
let alpha be 10 to the 15,
you can see that there's like
some possible problems here.
When you let alpha have
an enormous weight,
you're really
tilting this matrix
so strongly, you know, you
couldn't let it be 10 to the 20
in single precision or you'd
wipe out A transpose A.
So it's a balance here.
So I guess probably a lot
of a numerical analysts
would say wrong way to
do it, the right way
is solve this equation, or
else do it this other way.
But a lot of people with
codes say OK, you know,
you're going to be
a nervous Nellie,
I'm just going to use my code.
And that's quite normal,
quite human response.
OK.
And this will
frequently succeed.
OK.
So that's one method to
do it, not the method that
the professionals in numerical
analysis -- maybe I'm thinking,
for example, the book
by Golub/van Loan,
if you know that book, that
would discuss this problem.
And it would actually
discuss this third method,
this null space
method of solving it.
OK.
Maybe I'll go to that
null space method.
So this was one way.
Another way is
solve B*u equal d.
And remember again, we
only have p equations,
we have n unknowns,
so there's going
to be freedom in the solution.
So we have to identify
a particular solution,
there's a lot of freedom in
that particular solution,
and then we can add to it --
this null space is going to be
n minus p dimensions, n minus p
degrees of freedom in the null
space.
That's the dimension of
the null space, n minus p.
I'm assuming that
B has full rank p,
but p is a small
number compared to n.
OK.
So how do you find a
particular solution?
How do you find the
null space solution?
As I said, that's what I
should be explaining in 18.06.
And of course, we do it in
18.06, but we do it with a 3
by 3 matrix, and we practically,
you know, we do it by hand,
where here we're talking about
matrices of order thousands
or millions, we don't
do those by hand.
And we better not do
it in an unstable way.
So the question is what's
a good way to do it?
And really, the heart of
modern numerical analysis
is orthogonalize stuff,
get orthogonal vectors.
Because if you have
orthogonal vectors,
they don't get out of scale.
The numbers involved
don't become unstable.
And the standard
orthogonalization process
is Gram-Schmidt,
that's right, those
are the words we all think of.
If I have a bunch of vectors,
I have to make them orthogonal,
I want to make them
orthogonal, then I use -- well,
Gram-Schmidt is
what we think of.
But actually, MATLAB
doesn't use Gram-Schmidt,
doesn't use the
usual Gram-Schmidt,
as Gram and Schmidt
thought of it.
MATLAB goes a different
route to the same conclusion.
So let me just remind you
what Gram-Schmidt produced.
And let me put in the name
of the numerical analyst
long after Gram and
Schmidt, it's Householder,
you know, the guy from
Tennessee with good ideas.
So he had another way
to the same answer,
which is this factorization.
So we take our matrix,
often it's A in 18.06,
and we factor it, we want to
orthogonalize its columns.
So the columns of A
get orthogonalized
into the columns of Q. So this
has the orthogonal columns.
And then, of course,
there's some connection
between the original columns
and the orthogonal columns,
and that connection is
by triangular matrix
R, upper triangular.
I don't know if you
remember that from 18.06.
What I typically do is I explain
Gram-Schmidt as they knew it,
and then at the last
minute I pull Q and R out
as a way to express
the result. OK.
So it's the result
we want, and not
the particular Gram-Schmidt
way to get there,
and Householder produces
a better way to get there.
OK.
But the main point is that if a
matrix has independent columns,
or even if it hasn't, but if
it has independent columns
we know everything about it,
that we can orthogonalize
those columns.
In fact, we can -- here's
what I'm leading to, this B
transpose I'm remembering has
this shape because B had that
shape, so it's B transpose that
I'm going to do Gram-Schmidt,
Householder, use -- The command
in MATLAB is [Q, R] equals,
with Gram-Schmidt we could
have used the letters G and S,
but since we don't use
their actual method anymore,
we could use the letter HH
for Householder or something.
But it's qr of, in this case,
B transpose is what we want.
OK.
So what that very frequently
used command in MATLAB
produces is Q and R. And it
produces a square matrix Q,
where these columns, the
columns of the first part,
Q_1 transpose,
are orthogonalized
versions of these columns.
And the R just tells us the
connection between them.
Then it also produces, and
this is handy as you'll see,
the algorithm also produces
n minus p more columns, that
are orthogonal to these guys.
So it produces a complete
orthonormal basis,
a complete set of n
columns altogether.
Q_1 transpose has the
column that really are
associated with these problems.
And these are going to be
associated with the null space.
So out of this, I see
that actually B transpose
is Q_1 transpose
R. So you can say
this is the reduced
factorization with only p
columns, and this
is the full picture
with the other n minus p
columns that are orthogonal.
And the reason that's
handy is they tell us
about the null space.
So now I want to identify out
of this a particular solution
and the general
null space solution.
OK.
So what are those?
So particular solution is
going to use this part.
So, let's see, I want
a particular solution.
So B, transposing that
is R transpose Q_1.
OK.
So now I'm prepared to solve
-- step one is the particular
solution.
I want to get be
B*u_particular equal d.
OK.
But now I have B
is nicely factored.
So this is R transpose
Q_1 u particular equal d.
So now comes the computation
the code has to do.
It has to invert that to
get Q_1 times u particular
equals R inverse transpose d.
So it had to solve
a triangular system,
but of course, a triangular
system is quick to solve.
That's the good part here.
And then this final step
to get u particular,
I have to put the inverse
of that guy over there,
but because this has
orthogonal column, that's
just Q_1 transpose.
So there we go.
That's the inverse
of R. So that's
what I should've done
in 18.06 and never did,
and you get to see it.
What's a convenient
particular solution?
Everybody knows, we
got a whole collection
of particular solutions.
We want to choose one
that's nice and stable.
And the reason it's
stable is that it
works with orthogonal
columns, orthonormal even,
and triangular matrix for
which linear systems are
highly active.
OK.
So that's the
particular solution.
Now what's the null
space solution?
What are the general
solutions to null space part?
What are the solution to those?
Well, I can just go
down the same steps.
This is R transpose Q_1
u null space equals 0.
I multiply both sides --
this is a nice square,
invertible matrix -- I multiply
by its inverse, kills that.
So now I have Q_1 times the --
Q_1 is really the heart of B.
So what vectors are
perpendicular to Q_1?
I hope I've got this right.
It's easy to mix up a
transpose in the process.
So let me just pause to be
sure I'm doing it correctly.
OK.
I hope.
Did I check that I get it right?
Yes.
OK.
I could have written
what B is here, since I
have B transpose as a product.
B is R_0, Q_1, Q_2.
OK.
And I want to multiply
by u_null and get 0.
OK.
So what should u_null be?
u_null should be -- this
part is giving us a 0,
so this is like gone.
So you see the two are the same.
So what vectors are
perpendicular to those?
The answer is the u_null is
a combination of the columns
of Q_2 transpose.
It's the Q_2 part that's
telling us about the null space.
It was the Q_1 part that
gave the particular solution,
it's the Q_2 part that
gives the general solution.
In other words, u_null
is Q_2 transpose times
any vector, let me call
it z, this is any z.
OK.
Now this has my n minus
p degrees of freedom.
Sorry, I'm trying to
do quite a bit here.
I'm trying to say
how you actually
solve rectangular systems
when they're not determinate.
There are many solutions.
This is a good particular
solution to find,
and this is a good way to
find the general solution,
the null space solution.
This is a combination
of the other columns.
OK.
All right, now
we're done really,
because I now know
what u looks like; u
looks like this part,
which I've computed,
and this part, which
has the freedom.
Let me put those
two parts together.
So now I want to minimize --
so I'm near the end here --
A*u minus B, but
A*u is u_particular,
and I have u_particular here.
Q_1 transpose R
minus transpose d,
that's u_particular, plus
u_null, and that's this.
This u_null was also here;
u_null was any Q_2 transpose z,
right.
All that is u, A*u minus b.
OK.
Up to possibly screwing
up on some transposes,
this is the right method.
So this is a fixed solution.
I just want to write
that as a different way.
Minimize A Q transpose z.
Now, we're minimizing
over the z's.
So u had n components, but
somehow p degrees of freedom
were used up by the
constraint B*u equal d.
And we have the n minus
p true degrees of freedom
are in the z.
So there's this minus the b.
This is all known stuff.
A Q_1 transpose R minus
transpose d, square.
OK.
I'm there.
So this is a standard
minimization problem.
Minimize, shall I
call this A tilde z?
And I'll call all
this stuff b tilde.
And the solution is found
from the normal equations
A tilde transpose, A
tilde times the best
z, I'll put a hat
on it to emphasize
that it's the great one, is
A tilde transpose b tilde.
OK.
Finished that process
without leaving myself
a lot of time for
the other method.
Conclusion here, that after
you've done the QR step, the qr
command, and then after
you solved a linear system
with the R transpose, and you've
multiplied by Q's, and you've
ended up with this problem
with a new matrix A tilde and B
tilde, then you just
do the normal equation.
The web will have the code
that takes those steps,
reaches this conclusion,
and solves it.
OK.
So that's the null space method.
And it would be our
method of choice when --
so z has n minus p components.
If p is near n, then they're
not many z's and this
is highly efficient.
OK.
So the null space
method is one way to go.
Can I just in the
remaining minutes
go back to the Lagrange
multiplier idea?
So what's the Lagrange
So let me write
the problem again
as Lagrange would like it.
Minimize A*u minus b squared
subject to B*u equal d.
That's the problem
we're solving.
I should have
written it earlier.
Let me put a star here,
because this is our problem.
OK.
So one way to tackle it
was take that constraint,
give it a heavy weight.
That was method one.
Method two was solve this
constraint in full detail,
get the z's that remain
as degrees of freedom,
plug in u_particular plus
u null space into here,
and then you have
a problem in the z.
That's method two.
Now, so method
three is Lagrange.
So method three would say
OK, what does Lagrange do?
L, we call it the Lagrangian, he
takes this A*u minus b square,
and adds to it some
Lagrange multiplier,
and I'll use maybe the standard
lambda, times B*u minus d,
right?
That's Lagrange's idea.
You recognize Lagrange's idea.
Takes the constraint,
multiply it by a multiplier.
In fact this is p
constraints, so p lambdas.
Lambda's a vector
of p multipliers.
Not just a single one, because
we've got the p constraints.
And now what does Lagrange do?
He sets the derivative
dL / d lambda -- well,
so let me do the dL/du first.
He sets dL/du to 0,
and dL / d lambda to 0.
I could've started
out with this method,
because it's going to lead
us to the equations faster.
What equations do we
get from dL/du equals 0?
What's the gradient
with respect to u?
That gives us A transpose A*u.
Oh, probably we want a 1/2
here, so that the numbers
come out right.
We get A transpose A*u, and
another u part will be the B
lambda.
Taking the derivative of u will
produce a B transpose lambda
out of that.
Yeah, a B transpose
lambda out of that.
And then, in here will
be a linear term in u
that we might as well put
on the right-hand side
as A transpose b.
Familiar.
OK.
And what about dL / d lambda?
Well that's just our
constraint, B*u equals d right.
Having built in the
constraint, when
I take the derivative
with respect to lambda,
the constraint just
comes back again.
So this is now method three.
Solve that system.
And I guess what I want say
in the remaining 30 seconds
is that solving this system
is the same as this one.
Those two are exactly the same.
So that's a system with three
parts, but I can, as always --
maybe I can even get there.
Can you see that
if I take this part
and I subtract A transpose
times the top row
from the bottom row,
what will that give me?
Let me just hope that it
works, well I won't actually.
Time is up, it's asking
too much to do even
this one piece of linear algebra
that can be in the notes.
So this system that we got
as the correct limit equation
is exactly the same
one that Lagrange gets.
So that's one way.
This is a system with
n plus p unknowns.
That's the price you pay
for going Lagrange's route.
You add p unknowns.
This was a system with
n minus p unknowns.
That's because you're
using the constraints
to reduce the problem.
And the original method one
was a method with n unknowns,
the unknowns in u.
So you have the choice n, n
plus p that Lagrange would like,
and n minus p that
Golub/van Loan would prefer.
And usually it's method two or
method three is recommended,
but method one often used.
OK.
So that's the lecture
on this point.
That's today.
And then next week comes
the whole class of problems
like finding velocities
from displacements,
where alpha is a
small parameter.
And then after that come
discussions of the completed
project ones, and the upcoming
extensions into project two.
OK.
See you next week, thanks.
Good.